la question de base pour moi c'est
qu'est ce que vous vouliez la radio sur
le plan territorial alors évidemment ça
c'était que du québec ya pas de tour ça
mais la question qu'on me touche
chercher à se poser c'est qu'est ce que
le québec c'est à dire comment définir
le québec comme communauté politique
comme communautés historiques comme
peuple comme nation et alors là à partir
de là on ne peut pas le réduire à une
simple association d'individus chacun
blindés dans leurs droits
il faut le définir à la manière d'une
entité historique d'une réalité
historique qui se transforme mais qui
composent qui comporte une part de
permanence où l'identité mois voilà je
dis que sur le fond des choses
le québec s'ancre le peuple québécois
s'ancre dans ce que j'appelle la
majorité historique francophone et la
vocation des nouveaux arrivants et de
prendre le pli de cette majorité
historique francophone
alors évidemment lorsque les nouveaux
arrivants s'y intègre il y amène quelque
chose elle se transformer
fondamentalement le geste d'adhésion
vient de ce côté donc il s'agit de
d'adhérer à cette nation de s'approprier
cette mémoire dix amants de reconnaître
que le français n'est pas qu'une langue
sur deux mais la langue fondatrice de la
nation
à partir de là il ya évidemment une
minorité historique anglo québécoise
dont les droits sont confirmés sont
reconnus mais on ne peut penser
l'identité du québec sans l'entente
d'abord dans la majorité historique
francophone sans quoi elle perd toute
consistance en quoi le québec ne se
distingue plus fondamentalement de
l'ontario du manitoba du prince édouard
et suit donc là le québec que ce que
c'est d'une certaine manière c'est la
communauté politique qui poursuit la
longue aventure de l'amérique française
sur quatre siècles et qu'il incarne
aujourd'hui et que l'on peut souhaiter
absolument ouverte à ceux qui la
rejoignent
mais pour cela doit assumer ça pour son
propre héritage historique